[Music]
Red Lobster has the best friend it's all
about Red Lobster my mom's bread is the
best Outback Steakhouse it is yes it is
I love it so much it's so good and I see
it do you have any butter brown means
healthier right it's so true there's
like bread that you eat the inside out
of mm-hmm this is it good I don't
discriminate if you put bread in firing
me I will always eat it it's like not
dripping in any sort of oil
I have wish it was I'll give it a 5 Wow
- it's here bro we're talking about
bread no I don't like raisins and things
cuz you think it's chocolate and then
it's not it's the rudest surprise it has
carrots in it I hate carrots but I like
but you know what maybe it's like
healthy but it's actually good healthy
this is a breakfast bread like mom why
are you giving me this is this something
grandma I'm getting a little oil on my
on my fingers it's probably you just put
that underneath your eyes some lip balm
you get lip balm
[Laughter]
we know what this is we're limited
breadsticks whoa is it I was garden it
looks like it would be like somewhat
good but it just was disappointing mmm
makes me think of arguments with my
parents we always argue at Olive Garden
I feel like I remember it being so much
better flavor 9 bread itself 3 this
brown one looks good you and the brown
woman whoa my favorite bread in the
world baby this is I believe the Outback
Steakhouse oh okay nope nope no that's a
pleasant surprise
absolutely I think I know what to expect
whoa this is heavy oh wow like this is
huge
oh my god the yeast enos on it that's a
girl put it in your mouth I was never a
fan of this type of bride I mean Winnie
the Pooh would love it oh my god oh my
god orgasm now to me this is perfect
I'm so excited for this last one or
something there back where I'm from used
to sneak this into there / everyone done
oh really okay red heaven reven it
doesn't need butter no it has butter in
it look at the little pieces of butter
they like inject it mm-hmm Red Lobster
Texas Roadhouse like without butter
this was a surprise contender picked
everybody else said it's no good butter
Red Lobster Red Lobster don't eat the
lobster just eat these that's all you
need to eat
Red Lobster yeah let's pretend like
we're all surprised
I just really love carbs a lot I love
cars too and just love them so much
wrong you know what it can't something
that feels so right cannot be wrong